Trascrizione: Agnese Giacomelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
E se vi chiedessi quali sono le soluzioni
per contrastare il cambiamento climatico,
voi che cosa mi rispondereste?
Sì, lo so cosa state pensando:
macchine elettriche; pale eoliche;
pannelli fotovoltaici;
navicelle aerospaziali
per colonizzare Marte;
soluzioni ingegneristiche
che con straordinari macchinari,
e calcoli complessi,
si impongono di ridurre
le emissioni di CO2 in atmosfera,
pur continuando a vivere, però,
come abbiamo sempre fatto.
Ebbene, di fronte a problemi
che delle volte ci sembrano
insormontabili,
basterebbe fermarsi un attimo
e osservare chi ha a che fare
con questi problemi da milioni di anni:
la natura.
Ci siamo sempre focalizzati
sulla risoluzione strettamente
tecnologica del problema,
dimenticando tuttavia
il contributo fondamentale
che gli ecosistemi naturali
possono offrire,
nel contrastare il cambiamento climatico,
in quanto sono incredibili serbatoi
di carbonio e di biodiversità.
Biodiversità,
questa parola che oggi è un po'
sulla bocca di tutti:
Ma cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire diversità in specie,
diversità in forme, in colori,
in dimensioni, in diversità -
in soluzioni.
Gli ecosistemi naturali, infatti,
col loro complesso intreccio
tra tutte le componenti abiotiche -
l'acqua, l'aria, il suolo -
e biotiche -
tutte le specie vegetali e animali
che compongono il nostro pianeta -
sono infatti in grado di fornire
qualcosa di indispensabile
al nostro sistema:
la resilienza.
Che rende il nostro sistema
in grado di rispondere
a un qualsiasi evento perturbante.
Per secoli, il genere umano
si è ispirato alla natura,
osservando ed imparando.
Pensate alla nostra vita quotidiana.
Pensate al colore dei nostri tessuti,
ai farmaci,
al cibo che portiamo sulla nostra tavola,
al volo dei droni, degli elicotteri,
ai colori stessi.
Così la natura, allo stesso modo,
può aiutarci nel trovare le soluzioni
per contrastare il cambiamento climatico
che sta rischiando di portare al collasso
la nostra e moltissime altre specie.
Il carbonio,
che noi tutti tristemente associamo
al cambiamento climatico,
è in realtà la componente fondamentale
di tutta la materia organica.
È l'elemento base che ha permesso la vita
a organismi come noi,
e tutta la restante diversità vivente.
Il nostro pianeta, questo elemento,
lo conosce molto bene.
Da miliardi di anni, infatti,
lo scambia e lo combina
nei cicli tra gli esseri viventi e non.
Parte di questo carbonio
può venire sequestrato e immagazzinato
all'interno dei cosiddetti serbatoi
di carbonio naturale,
che altro non sono, però, che ecosistemi,
in tutta la loro semplice complessità.
Certo, non dobbiamo immaginarci
questi serbatoi di carbonio
come dei compartimenti a presa stagna
che, come per magia, intrappolano
l'anidride carbonica in eccesso
e risolvono il nostro problema.
Ma più come elementi del sistema naturale,
gli alberi, le rocce, il suolo,
i gusci stessi degli animali:
sono tutti serbatoi di carbonio naturale.
In questo piccolo esempio
che vi porto, in questo paper,
sono stati calcolati i mega grammi di CO2
intrappolati in diversi
ecosistemi terrestri.
Per esempio, in un normale prato
possono venire immagazzinati
fino a 200 mega grammi
di carbonio per ettaro;
mentre in una zona umida -
che il nostro territorio conosce bene,
o perlomeno conosceva bene -
fino a 400 mega grammi.
La domanda che oggi vi faccio è questa:
di fronte alle immagini come queste,
di ghiacciai che si sciolgono,
gli orsi polari scheletrici,
di incendi devastanti
che privano della propria casa
i cuccioli di orangotango,
e di isole di rifiuti galleggianti
che inondano i mari di tutto il mondo,
quante volte ci siamo sentiti
impotenti, frustrati?
Certo, i governi di tutto il mondo
devono iniziare a prendere
decisioni più lungimiranti,
che mirino a tutelare
gli ecosistemi e la loro biodiversità;
ma nel nostro piccolo?
Siamo sempre abituati
a pensare alla natura
come qualcosa di lontano da noi.
Che ci vogliano ore di macchina,
se non addirittura di aereo,
per raggiungerla.
O che l'unico modo di apprezzarla
sia attraverso coloratissimi documentari
di Discovery Channel.
Ma noi siamo nella natura:
e attraverso piccole,
e veramente semplici,
opere di "Regreening",
le nostre città,
e addirittura i nostri semplici
balconi di casa, o i giardini,
possono diventare incredibili
serbatoi di biodiversità.
Certo, qui non siamo al Polo Nord,
non stiamo salvando
direttamente l'Orso polare;
ma stiamo contribuendo
a tutelare un anello
di quella lunga catena
che compone gli ecosistemi,
dove ad ogni nostra azione
corrisponde una risposta.
E se ci impegniamo a tutelare
la natura dietro casa,
stiamo finalmente diventando attori
di quel cambiamento
di cui noi ora stiamo soltanto parlando.
Certo, il cambiamento è difficile:
cosa serve per cambiare?
Be', secondo me la sfida
sarà soprattutto culturale:
e dovremmo aiutare la natura ad aiutarci,
accogliendo nuovamente la vita selvatica
all'interno delle nostre vite.
Ma come farlo?
Sembrano parole difficilissime.
Io, per esempio,
nel mio Comune sono conosciuta
come la pazza che vuole
la giungla nelle aiuole: la Savana.
Un'immagine che mi dipinge
tra il bucolico e il disprezzo,
perché chiedo, semplicemente,
di non sfalciare l'erba
costantemente in estate.
Seppur questa idea possa sembrare
culturalmente folle,
a livello scientifico, invece,
trova un forte riscontro positivo,
evidenziando come lasciare,
e ricreare, piccoli ecosistemi,
anche in contesti urbani
fortemente antropizzati,
migliori non solo l'ambiente,
ma anche l'umore delle persone.
Qui vi propongo due immagini.
La prima che vedete
è il classico prato cosiddetto
"all'inglese", regolarmente sfalciato.
Il secondo, invece,
è un prato lasciato a libera evoluzione,
non sfalciato costantemente.
In questa ricerca sono stati calcolati
la quantità di insetti impollinatori -
che noi oggi conosciamo benissimo,
che sono in tutte le pubblicità -
In un prato e nell'altro.
Ma deve sorprendere
che nella seconda immagine,
quindi nel secondo ambiente,
ci siano tre volte il numero di specie
rispetto al prato all'inglese?
Quindi, ora vi chiedo:
dov'è il serbatoio di biodiversità?
Con quale delle due ipotesi
stiamo contrastando
il cambiamento climatico?
Ma può l'erba alta,
lasciata nel mio giardino,
tutelare l'orangotango in Asia?
Sì: indirettamente, sì.
Così per molti, purtroppo,
io continuerò ad essere la pazza
che vuole la giungla nelle aiuole;
ma per altri sarò un esempio
di come essere una goccia
che conta in mezzo al mare.
Farlo, guardate bene, è facile:
delle volte molto più semplice,
economico, meno faticoso,
meno dispendioso.
E soprattutto,
non si disturbano i vicini
nelle calde mattinate estive.
Ma come salvare il mondo, la biodiversità,
contrastare il cambiamento climatico
comodamente dal nostro divano di casa?
Per esempio, ricreiamo piccole zone umide
nei nostri giardini privati, o pubblici.
Aiutiamo la flora e la fauna autoctona.
So che la biscia vi sta tutti
a tutti un po' - che schifo!
Però io l'ho messa lo stesso,
perché serve anche lei.
Quando volete piantare un albero,
scegliete essenze autoctone.
Essenze cioè che vivono
in questo ecosistema da milioni di anni,
hanno un ruolo all'interno di ecosistemi;
e costeranno anche molto meno.
Le foglie, il legno morto,
non sono dei rifiuti: sono una risorsa.
Incominciamo a capirlo.
Ma poi, tutto sommato,
un po' di disordine è una cosa buona:
è stimolante, è divertente -
e meno faticoso.
Certo, un po' meno
per i maniaci dell'ordine.
Quello che oggi voglio dirvi
è che sicuramente la tecnologia
ha fatto passi da gigante:
ha migliorato le nostre vite,
aiutandoci a superare problemi
che difficilmente avremmo risolto senza.
Ma la natura è l'unica fonte
di risorse di cui disponiamo,
perché noi non ci possiamo nutrire
né di computer, né di reti wireless.
Quindi, in un'epoca di grandi cambiamenti
come quella che stiamo vivendo,
sarà fondamentale, indispensabile,
associare all'avanzamento tecnologico
il ripristino degli ambienti naturali,
permettendo alla componente selvatica
del nostro pianeta di ridarci la speranza.
È un po' come quando perdi qualcosa,
e sei costretto a ritornare
sui tuoi passi per ritrovarla.
Allo stesso modo, la nostra specie
deve avere il coraggio
di fermarsi, voltarsi
e guardare al futuro,
riscoprendo nella tecnologia più vecchia
e avanzata di sempre le soluzioni:
la natura.
E non c'è niente di più rassicurante
di sapere che tutti, nel nostro piccolo,
possiamo fare davvero qualcosa.
E chiederlo poi nel nostro grande.
Grazie.
(Applausi)